[Applause]
northern ireland's ports where the
problems of brexit are still playing out
now the uk government taking action to
unilaterally move most checks on trade
in goods from great britain to northern
ireland rowing back on a treaty long
signed with the eu
presentation of bill
northern ireland protocol bill this
legislation rips up part of the brexit
deal boris johnson signed in 2020 in
four key ways
it wants to create a check-free green
lane for goods that enter northern
ireland and don't go onto the republic
of ireland which is part of the european
union a dual regulatory regime meaning
goods could be sold in northern ireland
if they meet either uk or eu standards
new freedoms to provide financial
assistance to companies in northern
ireland and change vat rates
and it wants the european courts to stop
having a final say in disputes how
comfortable are you with the uk being
seen around the world as a rule breaker
instead of a rule enforcer
we're very clear that we're acting in
line with the law what is vitally
important
is that we do resolve this situation in
northern ireland that is causing real
problems the eu have refused to change
the protocol which is causing these
problems on trade on tax
and more broadly in northern ireland
but the eu say you signed it stick to it
and warns of retaliation the european
union will not renegotiate the protocol
unilateral action is damaging to mutual
trust
the commission will now assess the uk
draft legislation as the first step the
commission will consider continuing the
infringement procedure
a message reiterated by one key european
nation we are
forced because of uk action
to to respond to
what we certainly see as a breach of
international law i don't think there's
any other way to describe this if you
are legislating to set aside elements of
a of an international treaty which is
international law
uh well then you're breaking
international law
and north of the border unhappiness too
a majority of the northern ireland
assembly signing a joint letter to boris
johnson opposing what they say is a
reckless bill today's action by boris
johnson in westminster is absolutely
reckless it's disgraceful
it does nothing to serve the interests
of the people here it flies in the face
of an international agreement which he
himself negotiated it is in clear breach
of international law but for the dup
which won't support power sharing in the
northern ireland assembly until these
problems are fixed tentative support i
believe that
finally we are now seeing the kind of
action that is required
to begin the process
of
removing the barriers for trade within
the united kingdom
to restoring northern ireland's place
within the uk internal market for two
years now problems over trade between
london and brussels have been playing to
see but the solution proposed today only
serves to further stoke those divisions
with boris johnson pleasing his
brexiteers and the dup while angering
many in his own party brussels dublin
and washington dc many on both sides of
the argument will privately tell you
they don't think that the uk will in the
end enact this legislation that this is
a negotiating technique but it's one two
that will sour relations with old allies
on both sides of the atlantic and could
even eventually trigger a trade war with
the eu
that's an outcome some way off and one
no one wants but this trade route a
reminder that for all of the pm's
promises brexit's still not done beth
rigby sky news westminster